Mark: *exhale* Just,
Mark: Give me a sec- ah- well, I- the-
Mark: UNO was added to the list.
Mark: It's not even my fault because UNO was added in-
Mark: -at random.
Wade: We've played it before!
Mark: WE HAVEN'T PLAYED IT IN YEARS!
Mark: I have not played it this on THIS computer!
*angry table poking*
Mark: I-
Bob: It has literally been years.
Mark: It's been yEaRs! *mark intensifies*
Mark: There we go, here we go and I'm joining now,
Mark: Here we go. Wait for it-
Mark: -three, two, one-
Mark: I'm in.
Bob: ..Mine crashed.
Mark: *the long sigh*
Mark: I don't believe (x7)
Wade: Oh my god, I killed Mark
Bob: *laughing*
Mark: Kill me? Kill ME?! Why would
Mark: you k-
Wade: Yes, you!
Mark: What- ME?!
Bob: Can you-
Bob: Can you invite me to the game? *laughs*
Mark: Kill ME??? *mark is confusion*
Mark: Why ME?!
Wade: Because,
Wade: We've been in the game (for) so long,
Wade: they've come out with UNO 2.0 in the time that Bob and I have been waiting for you.
Mark: What IS this?
Bob: 'Cutie'? Oh-
Wade: 'Cutie'?
Mark: Just Dance 2017-
Mark: What is THIS?
Bob: *laughing*
Wade: This is Just Dance UNO!
Wade: You're welcome!
Mark: Wait I can't hear anything- Oh, there we go.
Mark: Wai- I wasn't ready!
Mark: Wait-
Wade: Well it's your turn now!
Mark: How do we play?
Bob: *increasing laughter*
Wade: CLICK A CARD!
Bob: It's-
Bob: -fucking UNO.
Mark: I- Okay, listen, listen, listen.
Wade: How does one play UNO?
Bob: *jokingly imitating* How do we play?
Mark: Okay, alright, that's just rude.
Wade: I have this mouse and these cards,
Mark: *Cue the sigh*
Bob: Oh god, I forgot you could jump in. Fuck-
Wade: Here you go Mark, have some cards.
Mark: I don't want some cards. ;-;
Bob: What? What is that rule, what happened? You played a 7?
Wade: Yeah, sevens trade hands-
Wade: *intelligible* -who you pick.
Mark: Hang on, I gotta go change the game options-
Mark: Don't- don't take my turn
Wade: It's your tuRN!
Mark: What do you mean it's-
Bob: It's your turn-
Mark: -my turn?
Bob: -right now! *laughing*
Mark: No it's nottt
Wade: Well, it was.
Bob: Oh, you drew a card. You drew-
Mark: What happened?
Bob: -two cards.
Mark: WHAT HAP-
Bob: You drew three cards.
Mark: WHAT'S HAPPENING?!
Bob: *intelligible* *laughing*
Mark: WHAT'S HAPPENING? WHAT HAPPENED- WHY?!
Mark: *sighs*
Wade: Ooh, special card..
Mark: What is that?
Mark: What is THAT?
Wade: I think everyone changes cards-
Wade: *laughing*
Bob: The fuck is happening? What is this?
Mark: Why is it Just Dance UNO?
Wade: This is Just Dance UNO!
Mark: I- p- asked what that was!!
ALL: *laughing*
Mark: I JUST asked!
Mark: Fuck youuu.
Wade: That's rude!
Bob: Just dance, yeah, dance,
Bob: just daaance. Yeahhh- oh fuck.
Bob: YEAHHH FUCK YOU.
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: ...Oh.
Bob: I don't know what that means, I just went for it.
Mark: G- you-
W:That means if they had a blue-
Wade: -card you would have won the challenge and they would have had to take four cards.
Mark: Dude-
Mark: -It hasn't been so long, but you can't have completely forgotten how to play UNO.
Wade: For example:
Wade: Bob, you made it red-
Bob: Red,
Wade: If Mark has a red,
Wade: He has to draw cards 'cause I challenged.
Wade: He does not - therefore, I'll draw six.
Mark: There you go,
Mark: You think I'm a lying motherfucker? YOU'RE a lying motherfucker.
Wade: I did it 1) because I don't trust you;
Wade: 2) to show Bob how it works;
Wade: and 3) 'cause I don't fucking trust you.
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: Listen, I think we're getting off on the wrong foot.
Bob: Look, I have an idea.
Wade: Yeah, yeah me.
Bob: gimme that
Mark: No- what- no!
Mark: No, NO!
B: Yeah, actually I have another idea.
Mark: No! NO!!!
Wade: Yeah me. Yeah me!
Mark: Wait,
Mark: what are you-
Bob: I won't do that one.
Wade: No!
Mark: What are you-
Bob: I don't know why I did that. That wasn't very useful, but that's fine.
Mark: I don't- I don't know why either,
Mark: But it- it was a good move, it was a good move, I think.
Bob: Haha, got 'em! Thanks Wade.
Wade: Yeah, I did-
W: Hey, it's me! I'm on the card. That's me!
Bob: That's you? How is that you?
Mark: That's you?
Mark: How is it you?
Wade: Bob, here, have these cards.
Bob: I, uhh..
Bob: Ah, I got options.
Wade: Yeah, there's lots of fun in there.
Bob: Well,
Bob: that's a pretty dick move there, computer.
Mark and Wade: *laughing*
Bob: Meheeeh.
Mark: Ah- shit. Ah, shit. *mumbles* There we go.
Wade: Aw, shit. Someone jump in.
Bob: Oh-
Wade: Why didn't someone jump in?
Bob: -A is jump in?
Bob: God dammit.
Wade: You can also just click the cards. You don't have to press the button.
Bob: I was pushing W frantically.
Wade: Ooh! *intelligible*
Wade:Alright, well computer, I don't have green, fuck you.
Bob: I- fucking hate this computer
Wade: Oh everyone gets a spaceship!
Mark: What is a spaceship?
Bob: What the actual fuck does that-
Wade: It's a random-
Bob: What does that mean?!
Mark: What does it do???
Wade: -It's a random card.
Mark: Oh, th- pfh-
Wade: And you skipped Bob!
Mark: Why is it called a spaceship?
Bob: You f- Whyy...
Wade: Oh, now I get skipped.
Bob: Awwwww.
Wade: That's pretty good.
Mark: I don't understand this.
Bob: What? Why? *laughing*
Wade: It's just UNO man, you know.
B: God dammit, fucking- you guys-... dickholes. Fuck-
Bob: Yeah, yeah. Take that. Ha ha.
Mark: Awww-
Mark: What did I do to you, Bob, what did I do?
Wade: *laughing*
Bob: Alright this isn't actually an improvement for me but..
Bob: It's just- eh, it's an improvement. Fine.
Mark: Okay, I don't know what happened.
Wade: Heyy...- Yaaay!
Mark: Oh, hey, I like this, this is good for me.
Wade: Nooooo!
Mark: *laughing manically*
Bob: Fuckinnn... You know it, baby.
Wade: Ooh.
Bob: Got 'em!
Wade: That's a nice double play.
Mark: Huh. You think that's gonna throw me? Nooo.
Bob: You un- relentless cunt.
Mark: You think that's gonna-
Mark: Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Mark: Wait what?
Bob: Oh, you-
Bob: -got wrecked.
Mark: Wait, what the fuck? No, I pressed that before you did.
Mark: There's no way! THERE'S NO FUCKING WAY, THERE'S NO FUCKING-
Mark: I CLICKED ON IT.
Mark: IT SAID-
Wade: *laughing* I heard it say UNO, before I clicked
*SMACK OF WIN*
Wade: Hey, game over. I win!
Mark: What? Wha- why- what the FUCK-
Mark: You ROBBED ME!
Mark: That's BULLSHIT!
Mark: No, wait, no, hang on. No, I clicked UNO!
Mark: The fuck is- WHAT??
Wade: *laughing* I heard it say UNO before I clicked the exclamation point.
Wade: It's all fucked dude- I dont know why.
Mark: It's- yeah, it said UNO!
*everyone but mark laughing*
Wade: I don't know why it-
Mark: EXACTLY! *sighs*
Mark: Whatever it's fine, it's fine. What is this shit?
Bob: I clicked, what the fuck?
Mark: I don't know what this is.
Bob: Oh I see, I see. What the hell?
Bob: Alright.
Wade: I guess it was Mark's turn, I don't know.
Mark: *sighs*
Bob: The fuck is happening?
Mark: I don't know.
Wade: That was funny. It was a good win!
Mark: No, it- no, it-
Mark: NO, it wasn't. NOT funny, not funny.
Bob: *laughing*
Mark: That's what it wasn't was, WADE.
Wade: That's what it wasn't was?
Bob: So what it wasn't was?
Wade: What's what it wasn't was?
Mark: That's what it wasn't was.
Bob: That's what it is is was.
Wade: Yeah, they tried to s- Cutie tried to screw me, but you sc- you screwed and now- now they screwed me.
Bob: I screwed- *laughs*
Mark: *laughs*
Wade: Yeah, have a sexy carrot fucker.
Mark: That's okay, I got a dancing...
Mark: ...man? *S M A C C*
Wade: Ooh, nice red. That's a nice red. Here you go, Mark.
Bob: Noooo-
Mark: Wait- you want my hand?
Mark: You fool, you fool! You fool!
Bob: Oh yeah, you can take Mark's, that's fine.
Wade: You- you can pass it forward play the seven.
Mark: You fool! You fool!
Wade: Take Bob's!
Mark: Oops!
Wade: There we go.
Mark: I'll take...
Mark: ...mine back. Give me that shit.
Bob: Yeah, that's probably a good call.
Wade: Alright.
Mark: Give me that shit.
Bob: Uhhhh...
Wade: Good play, good play. Good play boys.
Bob: I got 'em!
Mark: Well, what do you got?
Mark: Ahahahaha, you think that's gonna fool me?
Bob: Oh no. Oh dear.
Mark: Uh oh.
Wade: That's bad.
Mark: HAHA!
Mark: Caught him!
Bob: Oh shit-
Bob: Get wrecked-
Wade: Oh- now,
Wade: I don't want their hand. I want yours again.
Mark: What's wrong with mine?
Mark: I mean, what's good about mine?
Bob and Wade: *laughing*
Mark: You don't want mine!
Bob: *imitating* What's good about this? *intelligible* It's a bad hand! It's not good- aw fuck.
Now let me play these sevens played out and i feel much better
Well fuck everyone. Spaceship! Well that doesn't fuck everyone, that's a good for everybody right? I got fucked
Oh, yeah, you got fucked. Oh here comes a fuck
You would do the same to me
in a Heartbeat. I didn't do anything to you? You've done plenty to me my goodness you are a dill
Okay, I think we can all agree that the computers the real douche here, oh no, no no no, oh
Just what color they pick
i dont even know, im just gonna decline that one
Fuck, I wish there was a way to pass this along but I'm just outraged so.. no man, come on
Come on, come on, man. Come on, man. Oh
Yeah, Oh yeah!(4x)
Got him. All right. That's all Oh God you made it. Thank you for challenging marks. Now that it's red. I'm going to draw a
Little bit. No I don't it was good. It was not good. No, come on
Here we go. Ready here. I hate all of you a
Gangnam style guy let's play it. That's not Gangnam style guy
Its him, its him in mcdonalds outfit
No number five is Gangnam style
I thought I was gonna get that
*bob flips the fricken table*
Mark what is this shitty hand
Don't blame me I didn't get that. Oh wait that was my end. I didn't get that hand. That was your hand. Hey, what have you done to it?
I didn't do anything. You think uno happens it's bullshit Christmas experiment gone wrong. Sea ya bitch Oh, yeah
watch this magic
oh shit
oh yeah thats good stuff
I wanna play
*mark repeating "i wanna play"*
I hate you
what did i do?
you're a bad person. What? I'm not a bad person.
Got any blues over there Wade? I got 80s Weird Al
Well guess what uh
See, i'm gonna do, im gonna do the, the.. the
Oh god dammit why is it the computer!
Wait, so what color no I can okay. I can prevent that from happening at least.
Ah me too
why did you do this
I didnt want either of you to have uno!
We could of shared it
I don't know what
What what
Anything other than a number draw a card if they have blue I swear to God. Thank you
Better than you guys winning at least is it isnt an addictive party and I haven't won yet this round
Yeah we played one round!
Wait no shuck fuck you
oh yeah? How about this? And then a little bit of that action
nooo you jumped in on yourself
Yeah, see hm, you fool you can fool no I fucking hate y'all fucking
i fucking hate you
Its just like cackling of like " Oh its happening, Oh here we go "
oh naaah bro, oh nah bro, oh nah bro
Ah look who's- NOO
Haha alright thats not really much
who's fucking turn is it?
whats happening
The long slow delve into the realizations
oh no
ah come on
ah what are you gonna do now you fuckin aass
ohh fuck
gottem
Wait why would you do this, i  dont want to do this
You do you learning some
Weight so what are you where do you click to call the computer on uno because it's about to be at UNO and shit
It's a fucking
Bob: Alright, let's jump in bitch! Wade: NO I DON'T HAVE GREEN! Mark: Thank you. Thank you, Bob. Thank you.
Bob: They don't have green, so it's fine.
Oh, no, what does that hands? That means we're all down to two cards. Oh
shit
No, no, oh fuck well, I'm really sorry mark
You know what so sad so sad
You know, it's so sad
No fucking fuck you. Fuck you. You know what? That's fine. I'm whatever this is
I didn't get all of you
And you play anything but a number you draw oh fuck me how do you know it looks like you have two cards
Wait do i not-? Do I still draw? Oh thank god Hey i earned this
All of you, I hate you, why did you give him a good hand? Why did you do it? I didn't want you to win
how's that feel? wait what do you mean you didn't want me to win?
Why should you win Bob because I've never won I don't want anything today
I don't even fucking get my bait on the hook. All right, that's for catch a fish. That's fair. That's fair. That's fair
wait i didnt catch a fish either
No, no one cares wait oh, oh
haha cuck
I'm real. Sorry about this, buddy. Whoa. Listen, okay, listen, buddy, buddy
why green again!?
it better have green, bob. No it didnt
I'm really sorry about that, BUDDY. I hate all of you in this entire game so much
oh bob you have a good hand
No, I don't oh
Come on Bob man. I'm happy frien
Wait how good your hand? Oh great. Great. I mean great. I mean great. I just have to
*cracked voice* I wanna play the game too guys
*cracked voice* oh participate
Wade... I choose this one Wow. Okay, Molly brought me food. Oh
That's so no no. No
Fucking whatever that much
I didn't do that the computer did that. Thank you
Why did you have a shitty hand? You should have known - my entire fucking life doll. Here's some more for your life
That's my draw - that I was saving, but I didn't play against you on purpose
Okay, I believe that wait if you win it place wait, wait. Listen, let's talk about this. Oh wow
I say what you did
There's a problem with that hand if you're trying to win stuff you can always save that card for last
I don't even I have been paying attentions. I'm trying so hard my food
Don't eat food
I'm not yet mark take some time to stew on it
It's all guy at this point all I've got nobody insult my turn do it again
Okay, there's lots of good stuff fuck there's no way you don't have yellow know
These extra cards are weird as shop I'm fucking
I guess it wasn't for him
If he was drawing right wait, no, I'm not a fool in that. No, maybe I'm not a fool
No this one, oh, yeah. Yeah boy
Man that's really that's just rough, huh? Yeah real rough
There we go, okay. All right, no, no
Is that good did I do good? What is what is this? What is happening? What's happening? What happened? Oh, it's not
Oh, it's not a oh, it's not a it wasn't a number card. That's right. Forgot about that. Oh
Wait, so is that the whole time now it goes? Yeah. Oh
God but not so fast I've screwed myself up because I just draw
I just I see something flashing. I'm like I should put the bottom there ha sure I saw that and then I do it is
A good sequence. I love it
Other people look wait, I've got it kind of good stuff
What does that do
I was doing fine. I was doing fine. I was doing fine. I was doing fine
It doesn't matter
Here also had three cards that was probably better don't care. I just really want to click on stuff
I miss clicking on stuff guys
Do you remember when I used to play do stuff you remember? Ow?
I don't know. Actually I used to do so many stuff
Just good. Just good just good. Just so just good stuff. Yeah
Good stuff Wow
Good play Bob. Good play good play Bob. Good play
I got him again
That's a good play that's a good why are you gonna change the color like that if you want me to help you
Never mind got one
Was that a good bit too felt like the good bit? Okay
Wait, what the fuck? It's all I can do
Fuck let's give me something that makes weight said mark help me. No, why would that doesn't help me?
Just not that my third win in a row I need it guys know it just like you immensely no mark
Look, it's fine. See thank God. See it's fine
Cocks it's okay. Look at this. Wait
So long as everyone's unhappy
I got four of them. I'm good. What above and beyond look look guys. It's like golf the more you get the better, right?
It is fun to have a lot of cards and to drop some D's on some people already fun. Pretty fun
Haha, that's my turn no, it's not oh there's a problem here well
Take mine me I guess that's fine. I know what's gonna happen now. Yeah, that's the stuff. That's good
Damn it. Wait, please zero for God's sake please here. I draw
Think about it. Think about it think about it now, you're a fool who
Knows just played with like normal cards that don't do weird amazing things. Let me like
Why this I'm not gonna have this for a while
Take it right from me. I'm gonna lose this it's gonna be gone
Im losing it
YES! what?!
holy shit!! it was a five!
I didnt realize it was a five!
It was your hand, wade!! Only for a second!
It was your hand, wade!
bob come on
This is cutie's fault your hand. It was your hand... Oh god, are we going again? You literally made that happen? Oh,
Good I get to go first
Good, it's fun stuff
Do it Wade... it's a good hand, Bob I didn't really want get rid of oh
I'll see about that personally
Its so good- noo
Oh it is a good hand, its a pretty good hand
AAAh no my other good hand
Just wanted to check it for you Bob on to make sure it was really good
ah glad you got a good peak at it
A little confirmation on what's going on in there? That's quality stuff. It's good stuff. Right, right. Oh, yeah
AHH
Haha How do you not have a draw 2 card
- you have like six cards
Like six card draw, i draw two - like this one. Oh
well, that's
Kind of rude. How do you not have a draw to bow before I only had four cards?
Fuck wait, no one fuck with it. No one fuck with it. I have a draw for I mark okay fine
I dropped my draw for was the blue. Don't worry. They don't know they don't know
Wow, they took it stupid
Problematic card in all of these hands
See this is where you goofed
I
Don't know what to do here Bob
the cards the fate of the
cards the cards wait orga cards
Yes
Thank you so much. I'd like to thank all my fans you really brought me here. I thank everyone for supporting me all these years
Finally I click a fucking card
Haha. Oh god. Are we going again? I've got good stuff. Alright, we'll play this game out
It's gonna be a two-hour game here. Whose turn is it? Oh, it's waste Ernie's baubles may take his hands
I don't really have that good stuff, but you're welcome or whatever
Well, you had good stuff I know cacao Wow, oh no, no no no no no
No
Was gonna do it again, it's awfully tame game so far
Okay, whoa damn still tame still very tail. Okay
Okay to calm the fuck down
buddy pow
What's up, pal? Good friend. He's just gonna just gonna be like that. Yeah, man
Did you get drunk in the last two seconds I
Didn't want to do
This what is this we all are down to some yards we're done three, well, not really
Textbook YouTube YouTube
Overreaction Oh
Ali-a playing some uno. Holy shit. Sorry
Sick burn there Bob got'em, you really got him? Oh
Well, hey listen, I think you might be goofing me I think there's ever a situation where you're goofing me
I think it would be now because at least
We're friends Oh bitch. Oh
Shit what the hell okay
Wait, there's a thing I should do here. Yeah, do it- 90% sure. It's that.
Wha-Why would you do that? x3
Good guys, I forgot what my last card was.
No, how do you not-you JUST looked at it!
Jesus Christ, yes. Okay. Oh, you got it- it's all you bud. Okay, let's just kill it. Oh, yeah, come on wade, bring it home
Pile it on him, pile it on him. Wade
Yeahh. Oh shit
I feel like a dirty girl now. M: oh? eh?? B: Fuck me in the ear holes. M: *confusion*What????? B: Oh, heyy
Hey, listen, I'm just gonna do this
Oh no, no, oh, okay. I don't even have a good hand. I thought I had a good hand turns out shit. I keep losing my- oh fuck
Just hear it. Listen, it's fine. Just why is that good? It's blue good for you, buddy
Oh, wait. Wait, hang on
Ookay, that's an option
Oh
Come on no, it's okay
Please
Come on
There. All right. What's a good color mark? Oh, it's gonna be good. That's good. That's good. That's what I want
You sure you don't want a fucking reverse it. Nah, man, why?
No, that's not what I want no, no, I have the next few cards. Oh
Shit oh god. Wait, no. Wait. No. I have nothing but not those cards
I'll just leave it one color for like
Not the same color, I know I know matter what I have to draw
Yes, you're welcome everybody else
Wait your turn no no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
We should hit the Harley I don't know what you want and I probably picked wrong
and I've got fucked but
No, no no
BUT THAT COUNTS AS A WILD
ITS A SPACESHIP
YOU COULD OF PLAYED IT
yeah but I didnt want to
This just went downhill quickly
When you draw a card me about this
Disco thing is such bullshit
Alright
Somebody fucking reverse this shit, please
No, no, don't do it. Okay, don't go reverse it donors
Oh you
Fucker Wow goddamn Savage do anything. He's just been over there having a good time
How do you have so many of those hey, how's it feel I
Took your hand once I took you around once and I was it there's no way there's no way
Bob: Yeah, you had reds, you fuck! (Mark: Ho-ho! Ho-ho-ho)e right? You had reds, you fuck. You unbelievable FUCK!
Wade:Oh, FUCK YOU! WHAT THE shitty shitty fucking bang bang is wrong with you?!?
I just play the game man hate the play what the shitty shitty fucking gang bang is wrong with ya
Oh
My god
It's over it's over it's finally over
Wade: Just.. how do I quit this game-there we go. Heart of the cards, guys?
(Everyone just repeating "Heart of the Cards")
Love you all! (love you too mark)